[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute mache ich eine Spargelcremesuppe,
wie schon angekündigt.
Und dafür habe ich hier schon Suppenspargel.
Suppenspargel ist einfach ein etwas zarterer Spargel,
etwas dünner.
Und das Besondere daran ist,
ihr müsst wirklich nur den unteren Teil wegschälen.
Denn hier oben ist er gar nicht hart und
zäh.
Man kann den einfach wirklich wunderbar mitessen.
Ich habe den jetzt auch schon geschält
und habe auch noch
von unserem Spargelessen von gestern Schale übrig.
Und die nehme ich jetzt
– die ist schon gewaschen –
und werde sie jetzt gleich im Wasser kochen,
damit ich einfach den vollen Spargelgeschmack habe.
Also so viel dazu.
Ich brauche eben diese Spargelschale
und dann habe ich hier noch restliche Zutaten für die Suppe.
Dafür nehme ich etwas Butter
und Mehl für die Mehlschwitze.
Hier habe ich Suppenspargel,
etwas Zucker,
Sahne,
eine Zitrone zum Abschmecken,
Salz und Pfeffer.
Hier gebe ich jetzt schon mal die Spargelschale ins Wasser.
Das ist auch das Wasser,
was ich später zum Kochen der Suppe benutze.
Den lasse ich jetzt hier
etwa fünf Minuten kochen.
So habe ich den Spargelgeschmack
einfach schon mal im Wasser mit dabei.
Ich gebe jetzt hier noch einen Deckel drauf.
Perfekt!
Ich kann jetzt hier schon mal die Mehlschwitze machen
und die Butter in einem separaten Topf erwärmen.
Das ist der Topf, in dem ich gleich die Suppe mache.
Ich habe den jetzt hier auf mittelhohe Hitze gestellt,
dass die Butter einfach nicht zu schnell heiß wird und spritzt.
Wenn ihr mit Gusseisen kocht,
dann solltet ihr allgemein beachten,
dass ihr etwas gefühlvoller kochen müsst.
Also,
wenn ihr da auf zu hohe Hitze geht,
brennt euch alles an,
weil einfach der Topf die Temperatur perfekt speichert.
Zu niedrige Hitze ist aber auch nicht immer gut.
Da einfach gefühlvoll.
Ich habe das jetzt hier auf,
wie gesagt, auf mittelhoher Hitze,
auf Stufe 6 von 9,
lasse es schön langsam schmelzen.
Jetzt kann ich hier das Mehl dazu geben
und einfach langsam anschwitzen,
bis es eine hellbraune, schöne Farbe bekommt.
Hier nehme ich jetzt etwas
eine höhere Stufe.
Und in der Zwischenzeit kann ich mich
auch schon mal um den Spargel kümmern.
Da werde ich es jetzt nämlich so machen,
dass ich den Spargelkopf getrennt abschneide
und die restlichen Stücke einfach
in etwa so 3 bis 4 cm Stücke schneide.
[Musik]
Die Spargelköpfe sind immer etwas schneller gar.
Deswegen
will ich jetzt ja nicht, dass sie zermatschen.
Also bewahre ich die jetzt separat auf.
Und der restliche Spargel
kommt hier in eine Schüssel.
[Musik]
Den Spargelsud siebe ich jetzt hier noch kurz ab
und kann jetzt hier schon mal löffelweise den Sud
zur Mehlschwitze dazu geben.
Schön rühren, damit sich kleine
keine Klümpchen bilden.
[Musik]
Und jetzt schön wieder aufkochen lassen.
Da kann ich jetzt direkt etwas Zucker dazu geben.
Salz und Pfeffer.
[Musik]
Weißt du? Vorhin die ganze Zeit:
Sally, konzentrier dich! Konzentrier dich!
Nicht die Köpfe zum Rest! Nicht die Köpfe zum Rest!
Und dann
>> JOSH: Jetzt kocht es.
>> SALLY: zack.
Was macht sie?
Schüttet die Spargelköpfe zum Rest.
Ja.
Wenn man die Arbeit vorher macht
und sich dann auf die Suppe konzentriert,
kommt man nicht durcheinander.
Ich lasse jetzt hier die Suppe kurz etwa
fünf Minuten kochen.
Dann kommt der Spargel dazu,
also dieser Teil hier.
Und Suppenspargel braucht auch nicht so lange,
etwa nur fünf Minuten.
Das heißt, dann habe ich insgesamt
eine Kochzeit von zehn Minuten.
Und dann gebe ich
gleich noch die Köpfe dazu.
Aber jetzt warte ich erst mal noch.
Lassen wir jetzt so vor sich hin köcheln
und genießen das schöne Wetter.
Sollen wir noch eine Einlage dazu machen?
Laugenbrätchen?
Ja?
Wir machen noch eine Einlage.
>> JOSH: Was ist das?
>> SALLY: So Croûtons.
Oh! Mit Laugenbrezeln!
Okay. Ich räume hier kurz auf.
Dann machen wir noch Croûtons.
Also hier gebe ich jetzt die Spargelstücke mit rein,
lasse sie etwa fünf Minuten mitkochen.
Und ich schmecke jetzt auch direkt schon
die Suppe mit Zitronensaft ab.
Also ich mag Spargelcremesuppe
immer gerne mit Zitrone.
Ich mache mal aber nur ein bisschen.
Ich kann ja noch
nachwürzen.
Das behalte ich so zurück.
Die darf wieder weiterkochen.
Und hier kann ich jetzt schon mal die Croûtons machen.
Ich habe hier einfach
drei Laugenstangen von gestern noch übrig.
Die sind schon ziemlich trocken,
wie man sieht.
Die schneide ich jetzt in Würfel.
Theoretisch kann ich schon ein paar in die Pfanne geben.
Ihr könnt euch die Schüssel auch sparen.
Ich dachte nur, ich kriege nicht alle auf einmal rein.
Da habe ich schon Olivenöl drin.
Mit Butter schmeckt es auch gut.
Butter-Croûtons.
Und dann habe ich hier noch Knoblauch.
Den schneide ich
einfach in feine Scheiben.
Nee, ich hacke ihn noch ein bisschen.
So.
Ta-daa!
Der kommt noch rein.
Und dann eigentlich nur noch Salz und Pfeffer.
So lieben wir unsere Croûtons.
Und ihr könnt die auch so vermischen mit dem Öl
oder mit der flüssigen Butter
und auf ein Backblech geben.
Siehst du? Deswegen.
Deswegen wollte ich zwei Schüsseln nehmen.
Und auf ein Backblech geben und dann im Ofen backen
oder halt kurz in der Pfanne.
Aber ich brauche
noch ein bisschen Öl.
Tatsache.
[Musik]
Ich schöpfe jetzt hier ein paar Spargelenden raus.
Die will ich nämlich nicht mitpürieren.
[Musik]
Und den Rest
werde ich jetzt kurz im Topf pürieren.
Wird sie schön sämig.
So mache ich es auch bei Kartoffelsuppe.
Einen Teil mitpürieren, einen Teil nicht.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich hier die Spargelköpfe dazu geben.
Den
restlichen Spargel dazu geben.
Noch mal ganz kurz kochen lassen.
Und dann muss ich es eigentlich
nur noch mit der Sahne abschmecken
und fertig!
[Musik]
Spargelcremesuppe!
>> MURAT: Jawoll!
90°C Spargelcremesuppe.
>> SALLY: 100°C.
>> MURAT: Ja, ich sage das,
ich sage das bei jedem Suppenvideo eigentlich,
dass eine Suppe
nie so ein, so ein...
So fame wird.
Also das hat nichts mit Motivtorten zu tun.
>> SALLY: Warte. Ich rutsche mal ins Bild.
>> MURAT: Was ist?
>> SALLY: So.
>> MURAT: Ah, okay.
So.
Und dabei ist eine Suppe so was Wichtiges!
Und glaubt mir!
Wenn ihr mehr Suppen essen würdet,
dann würdet ihr vielleicht
auch nicht so
>> SALLY: Zunehmen?
>> MURAT: zunehmen.
Ja.
Ich könnte öfters auch Suppe essen.
Ist mir gerade eingefallen.
So.
Weil die Suppe ist
ein tolles Ding!
Also A ist es günstig natürlich.
Eine Suppe ist günstig, richtig?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Außer man wirft halt irgendwelche
Morcheln rein, die dann...
>> SALLY: Oder...
Oder so Trüffel oder so.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Oder Fledermäuse.
>> SALLY: Aber das machen wir ja nicht.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Wir machen ja nur
>> SALLY: schwäbische Suppen.
>> MURAT: Das machen wir nicht.
Genau.
>> SALLY: So ist das.
>> MURAT: Und deswegen ist das
ein wirklich günstiges Rezept,
Essen.
Ich habe es total...
Tut mir leid.
>> SALLY: Ich habe sogar die Spargelschale benutzt.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Auf jeden Fall: Esst öfters Suppen!
Ganz wichtig!
Und teilt dieses Video!
Mein Gott! Ich weiß, es ist nicht eine Harry Potter Torte
oder was weiß ich.
Sally hat keinen Flughafen gebaut.
Aber teilt dieses Video, dass mehr Menschen Suppen essen!
>> SALLY: Wenn ich das machen würde,
wäre aber der schneller fertig als Berlin.
>> MURAT: Ja.
So ist es.
Ja. Der würde sogar landen.
>> SALLY: Ich würde sogar die Flugzeuge fliegen lassen.
>> MURAT: So. Also ich probiere hier.
>> SALLY: Probier. Aber trotzdem pusten.
>> MURAT: Coole Resteverwertung.
>> SALLY: Also
der Suppenspargel war keine Resteverwertung, aber
>> MURAT: Mmh!
die Schale.
>> MURAT: Leute!
So genial! Weißt du?
Wenn es keine Tütensuppe ist,
so was richtig Cooles!
Hm?
Was?
War da ein Haar?
>> SALLY: Nein, Spargel!
>> MURAT: Ach so.
>> SALLY: Magst du noch Croûtons?
>> MURAT: Au ja! Cool!
Auch eine Resteverwertung?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Weil bei uns ist es immer so,
morgens
bringt die Aylin immer für das ganze Team Brezeln mit
und dann gibt es halt irgendwelche Leute, die es nicht essen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Denn die Jungs essen gerne Laugenbrezeln,
wir Mädels nicht.
Denn wir werden davon schnell wieder hungrig.
Also machen wir Mädels immer gesundes Müsli
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: für alle.
Und unser Part ist dann praktisch
Croûtons für das Mittagessen oder Abendessen.
>> MURAT: Was willst du mehr?
Genial!
>> SALLY: Oder?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Coole Suppe! Coole Croûtons!
>> SALLY: Isst du nur die Suppe?
>> MURAT: Nein, ich will jetzt noch ein Wiener Schnitzel!
>> SALLY: Oh, perfekt! Dann kriegst du leider nicht
das Roastbeef, was ich gerade rosa gebraten habe,
>> SALLY: mit Kartoffeln aus dem Ofen und Paprika vom Grill.
>> MURAT: Komm, veräppel mich nicht.
>> MURAT: Ja, das stimmt nicht. Ich würde es riechen.
>> SALLY: Du hast gesagt: "Was willst du mehr?"
Also nimm du deine Suppe.
Macht die Suppe gerne nach!
Und ich wünsche euch viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
Ich träume seit Tagen von Wiener Schnitzel.
>> SALLY: Komm, Josh! Ich habe Roastbeef für dich.
Komm!
>> MURAT: Wiener Schnitzel. Ich träume seit Tagen
von Wiener Schnitzel. Ohne Spaß jetzt.
Ohne Witz.
Tschüss! Macht es gut!
[Musik]